Bảo chào mì sẽ giải thóc mửi bốn, sống biển cao từ sau để tà mết hướng bò Việt Nam.
Thế chúng thầm dịch bảo ký tưởng thì vẫn cột ra,
hôi mề bà giờ, vị chi tâm bảo chào mì ở vòng khoảng quế ra phía năm đậu vị bác,
môi chăm hai miso phía năm đậu kinh đồng.
Chinh vụ biển phía đông biển Trung phía Li,
sức só mệ nhất phung cật tâm bảo mệ cấp tâm, giải thóc mười.
Chí chuyển theo hướng tế bác, tóc bộ mười làm mề tham yệt lúc bát trên dường.
Sức bảo đến mề bà giờ mề hay mê lắm tham mười,
bảo chăm mì ở vòng khoảng quế bệ phía sống đậu vị bác,
môi chăm mề bệ phía không lộ kinh đồng.
Chinh vụ biển phía đông tụi vực bất biển đông.
Hết quần đảo hằng xa năm trăm đậu vị kilomét,
phía phía đông đồng bác,
sức só nạn nhất phung cạnh tâm bảo cấp mười một,
sát tóc mười bốn,
sí chuyển chuyệu thông hướng tây khoảng mề lắm kilomét trên dường,
đi vào viền đông.
Từ bài mi hai đến một chăm hai miso tiếp theo,
báo sí chuyển chuyệu theo hướng tây,
báo sợi ý được bệ lập đến 200 km,
cường độ tiếp tục vận hêm,
không biển phía đông khu vực bất bình đông,
só mệ cấp sống tất mười,
tư sáng mề ai mề từ thăm mười,
tăng lên tấp tán, tấp chính,
không gần tâm bảo đi qua tóc mười, tâm mười một,
sát tóc mười bốn,
sống biển theo bụi để sống mệ,
bung gần tâm báo nha sảo để tà mết,
biển đậu dự dối,
tàu thuyên hạt động cho các vùng huy hiện và trên,
đều có khả năng chức tắt lộn của rau,
lốc só mệ sống lớn.